[Applause]
I'm Tiger King Tiger king can you please
come join us oh we got the tiger King in
the building everybody fresh off his
Netflix success shirt
broke out of prison you needed clothes
tiger King um first of all I want to say
thank you so much for coming on the show
man I know you must be getting crazy
amounts of media you gotta stretch those
legs out for that Prince abs yeah that
Prince house is a big tiger all this
Prince Albert here you know why is your
ear blue duck is it what do you mean
that ear is something's wrong with that
year what do you mean oh what's wrong
no no in all seriousness no you do
something with your although that's my
has my ear pierced and what's wrong not
did you really not do you know that's
happening right now really bad blue yeah
did you just flip it or did you get
yours get my pierson-el someone get my
ear piercing out right come on Bob
okay Tiger King I get em off tiger cage
appears as Oh son did you put this
through your [ __ ] here I don't think
so dude you have a hematoma on your ear
Tiger king I'm really concerned about
you that almost you almost sacrificed
your [ __ ] ear for this Tiger King
we're really appreciated so Tiger King
okay so you have this amazing Netflix
series it's it's out and and and you've
taken some time out of your you know
lengthy prison sentence to come in here
and talk to us about what you
experienced right first of all where did
this love of Thai
come from because I hated [ __ ] so I got
into Tigers you know that's kind of what
happens he's so much you are a gay man
that's true yeah a lot of people they
might not know that within the first
couple episodes but you are like super
gay and I hope you don't think we have a
problem because we actually worked with
a gay guy his name is Mark he's not here
right now
how much teeth does yeah oh so now
you're known for taking guys straight
guys yeah and then making them gay wall
there with you yeah it's called dick
flippin dick flippin yeah okay good okay
so um how do you flip a dick it's the
lengthy process flipping a day I'll tell
you what you gotta bring them in you got
to ask him first I asked him oh say hey
how straight are you yeah it's all here
we could practice what is he straighter
is he all right so I'll say how straight
are you straight mostly straight all
right well when you watch porn do you
want the big one or you want the little
one sir not that straight and then I
[ __ ] them that's pretty much so is that
part of it no you didn't need them to
want myth and then and then if they just
want to interest and I'm sorry I have a
meth addiction that's what I meant
yeah anyone can have a meth addiction
that's the way I see you I'm an equal
opportunist you know they need like a
meth curiosity at least no I don't even
think they need more like a tight little
waistline and some big some big balls
that's all I need why do you like the
big balls Tiger King because you know
they're just fun to play with and you
know
at at a Travis's funeral users robes big
balls in my face so it just reminds me
of you know just reminds me of him
was that what you thought was most
appropriate to share at his funeral of
all the things that you guys did
together of all like the time so you can
yeah I just wanted I just want his mom
his mom was there so I wanted her to you
know to hear that fun story of us and I
also wanted her to hear my new song
here kitty-kitty that I sang at the
funeral in the actual uniform that I
wore in the music video I wanted
everyone to hear that yeah just in case
those clips are maybe used on the news
or something then people could reference
that song yeah I take a song I take a
very social media approach to my content
you know I make small content clips I
subtitle them and I put them out on
YouTube you know that's how I
revolutionize the animal game probably a
king myself so this guy is this [ __ ]
one of the one of the greats really
great and then a quarantine might happen
you know and then everybody in the
animal you know game might probably
start doing what you're talking about
Carol oh this [ __ ] caroled out of
Florida tell us about this [ __ ] Carol
man because she seemed to be causing so
many problems for you bro you she really
bothered you this [ __ ] do you think
it's because like she knows she could
never have you cuz you're not interested
I don't know what exactly it is I mean
her hubby Howie's is quite a looker so
I'm interested in him but I think as far
as Carol goes I just think she's jealous
of all the Cubs that I have I really
think that's it
I think she's jealous of the Cubs I
think that [ __ ] is a murderer too yeah
she killed her husband down here in
Florida saw that right yeah she fed him
to the tiger so I think she's just
jealous of what I have what do you think
it is um yeah I think she killed her I
think she killed her husband a hundred
percent I think I think she's jealous of
you because you found a way to get your
husband to kill himself like that's a
skill that's why you're the king he's
not she's just some bit you know cat
rescue [ __ ] Yeah right that's correct
um I think the she was a a [ __ ] piece
when she was younger she was a dying
yeah
did you think I know that you don't look
at them like that yeah I mean I could
see I could definitely see it yeah yeah
and I'm also pissed at her because she
stole her the name of our company what
was the name of your company big cat
entertainment and what was the name
first Big Cat Rescue
I mean if I had to go see something
obviously big cat entertainment right I
won't be entertained rescued who cares
about rescuing yeah
rescue implies there's something wrong
it's the worst part of the cat you're
rescuing it yes yeah you don't judge the
cat bettan easy to rescue yeah
no can you talk to us about doc antal a
little bit I was one of my favorite
characters I loved our cancer doc antal
was my mentor would you like about dark
anti-god that was nice yeah Bhagat a
bomb yeah bag of on dog game move on
Bhagwan Waits Bhagavan is how he but I
think it's so doc ah antal doc ant oh
yeah dark handle now did you feel while
watching this documentary that the the
documentarian the director of the
documentarian did you think that he that
he liked da cancel or dislike da cancel
what do you think that his personal
opinion on doc was I don't know I mean
doc Handelsman those guys you like them
or you love them you know that's that's
what we say how do you feel I love the
man he was my mentor I love that man doc
everything about no never know he had
all these ladies you know he was able to
train the Tigers and train the woman
right is that where you learn to train
your your however a little competition
there you know yeah yeah he would get
these young girls I would get these
young boys yeah now he didn't need meth
yeah but women are easier to tame you
had to compare men and women to animals
that you have to tame what's up man and
what's a woman yeah well a man is like a
tiger or a lion a woman's like a lemur
or a snail
[Laughter]
they sit there scoot around the leave a
little trail in that way they try to get
away we you can always follow how do you
come up with the amount of money that
you pay them a week we've noticed that
the employees at these zoos got paid a
very minimal minimum wage you were
paying your guys $150 a week
$120 we get was it a hundred twenty yeah
138 and sixty-seven cents - taxes yeah I
mean our base is hey how much were you
making in jail and then I would say
whatever that number isn't multiplied by
like 20 and they were making like $1 and
now I'm making $20 a day so really
they're looking at like a raise yes use
promotion for them so that's is that why
you got people from prison so it's such
a easy inflation oh of course not I got
people in prison I care about people and
I wanted to give people a chance to
bounce back and find themselves and
maybe get on meth to [ __ ] me so is my
dick yeah exactly so yeah I'm just a
yeah I'm trying to pull people up from
their dick straps
[Applause]
[Applause]